le jeu des ambassadeurs vous avez tous
jouer c'est un jeu de salon
ça va devenir aujourd'hui un jeu de
télévision il l'a déjà été d'ailleurs le
jeu des ambassadeurs et bien gérard
depardieu va essayer de me mais est
surtout de faire comprendre aux garçons
et à mademoiselle qui de turgot un titre
de film alors il s'agit d'un titre de
film
tout d'abord gérard vous précisera en
trois ans deux en un an 4 mo le titre et
puis il va vous le nie mais et en deux
minutes
nous allons essayer de vous en faire
deviner les flip osieck attention
premier titre pas de m
comment regardez regardez d'un titre en
quatre mots la soupe au canard
non non non regardez comment c'est pas
un film final qu'il a joué lui un nom à
voile à la cuisse combien combien de
secondes 30 ce lundi les à notre titre
attention chronomètre
aouidat les ia les éditeurs pour
quelques dollars
non non non on tire toi non non mais
c'est pas bon les épaules et il a
l'argent les enfants les ans non non non
pas encore combien de temps une minute
et une minute de titres attention voilà
un autre os un autre à la ccyn banna i
go king kong
la belle et la bête et qui mime bien
sujet
attention le chronomètre repart allez-y
5 millions le titre 5 monde en titre ne
vous les hommes préférés ou voilà elle
sera tournée oullins une minute 40 g a
tranché il me reste encore 20 secondes
20 secondes pour un titre
au parlement oui oui car c'est parti
j'ai froid que la guerre du fonds non
non non non même les cavernes
des fois je pourrais vous est pas l
homme des cavernes mais non l'obs un
talent faisant le permis n'est pas un
saint jean